- Hello
- [Girl] We're gonna talk
- [Boy] We're gonna talk
- [Girl] about black history
- [Boy] about black history
(triumphant music)
- Harriet Tubman, she's just my hero,
she helped everyone out
when they needed it.
And she just saved everyone.
She snuck them out
and she used the big dipper
and freed eveyone.
Let's go, we will be free,
we'll just go at night with all of you
and go to the underground railroad,
and we'll go, be free,
and go together.
- [Voiceover] Thank you so
much, I really want to leave.
I don't know how long I could stay here,
but thank you so much,
you are a hero to us all.
- [Voiceover] We shall be free, let's go.
- Hey Journey, what was
life for the black people
back in the day?
- Well, it would be certain sections
where they would have to be able to sit.
- [Voiceover] Lady, you can't sit here!
- [Voiceover] Oh yeah?
- [Voiceover] Yeah!
- [Voiceover] You don't say that.
- You don't tell me what to do either.
Cause this is my bus,
Rosa Parks.
- [Voiceover] You are going to jail.
- [Voiceover] I don't care!
Some white people go to jail too.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, like, nobody.
Hello, cops, yes,
I am here,
and this black person won't leave
and just come here in
five minutes, please,
thank you.
- It is the right that black people
should sit in the front of the bus too.
- Martin Luther King Jr.
he's best known for advancing
the Civil Rights movement
and the I Have a Dream speech.
- It talked about getting
whites and blacks together
and making it a better place.
I have a dream that brothers and sisters
would unite.
There would be no more wars,
no more killing,
we would all have the
same equal education,
equal opportunity,
and we'd unite as one.
Malcolm X was a Civil Rights activist
and he was a spokesman
for the nation of Islam.
He believed to use the method of
by any means necessary.
- He changed his beliefs
and he just wanted us
to be together in peace,
just as Martin Luther King wanted.
So basically all black historic figures
are, in some way, the same
because they all wanted the same thing,
for us to come together in peace.
(whoosh)
(creak)